Fabián Becerra es un caminante Lleva más
de 20 años buscando la verdad por toda
Colombia aquí era el horno prematorio
que tenían aquí llegaban y lo atizaban
como dice metían la gente y lo quemaban
las quemaban ya venía muerto
descuartizados quemaban y después los lo
que quedaban lo sacaban lo metían a un
tanque
tanque con ácido sulfúrico para que no
quedara evidencia en 1999 su hija Carmen
Patricia tenía 12 años nunca regresó del
colegio el año pasado uno de los
paramilitares de las autodefensas Unidas
de Colombia le dijo que pudieron
quemarla en este horno en Juan frío a 10
minutos de su casa se la llevaron
cuentan por bonita Yo no sé qué Y mañana
o pasado mañana me maten o algo pero que
sepas mundo todo lo que pasó no tengo
miedo a contar la verdad durante todo
este tiempo los hornos desaparición han
estado ocultos en selvas de todo el país
se estima que los paramilitares quemaron
al menos 500 personas en el de Juan frío
entre 1999 y 2004 en el departamento de
norte de Santander fronterizo con
Venezuela
la comunidad limpia el lugar allí la
cancillería prepara un evento que
contará con la participación virtual del
que fuera líder de las autodefensas
Unidas de Colombia es una carta que fue
dirigida al Señor Salvatore mancuso a
Fabián le han pedido que le escriba al
responsable de la desaparición de su
hija son 24 años de dolor angustia y
querer saber dónde están tiene una
petición en particular y que él nos
pudiera comprar este pedazo de tierra Sí
para hacer una plazoleta un museo
histórico aquí Fabián también tiene
desaparecidos dos hermanos y un sobrino
junto a Juan frío Al otro lado del río
está Venezuela es porosa allí hay una
fosa común con al menos 200 cuerpos son
los colombianos que ni quemaron ni
fueron lanzados al río despedimos al
otro gobierno hay mucha verdad en
Venezuela y mucha verdad aquí en
Colombia Juan frío pertenece a Villa del
Rosario allí Simón Bolívar y Francisco
de Paula Santander proclamaron la
primera Constitución de Colombia donde
comenzó la historia también se escribió
la página de mayor horror un horror que
no cesa ser líder social en la zona es
todavía una profesión de riesgo esta
víctima nos pide ocultar su identidad
señala vínculos entre paramilitares y
políticos
en alcaldías que participaron de este
error lo hicieron por mantener ellos el
poder
hasta el día de hoy Aquí está mi foto de
la primera vez que fui alcalde en el año
2004 2007 la segunda que vi 2012-2015 y
la tercera
2020-2023 el actual alcalde de Villa del
Rosario es Carlos socha es su tercer
periodo durante 1999 y 2004 los años de
actividad de los hornos fue congresista
y también alcalde y gracias a mí a Dios
nunca me me amenazaron porque yo yo me
guardaba con Dios y ya me iba a alejarme
de esa gente que no me toque y no
conmigo No tuvieron ningún inconveniente
su enlace municipal de víctimas se exija
de un paramilitar de la época conocido
como hermides
por la paz por la memoria y por la vida
nunca más es el nombre del evento en los
hornos de Juan frío
detrás de la organización está Elena
urán su padre el magistrado urán fue
asesinado en 1985 durante la toma del
Palacio de justicia en Alemania
pero necesario
se llamó
durante gran parte de su vida vivió
exiliada en Alemania ha vuelto a
Colombia como asesora de no repetición
de la cancillería para traer el ejemplo
de construcción de memoria que sucedió
tras la derrota nazi y la primera vez
regresé a la casa muy impactada y le
comenté a mi hijo que había que llegaba
del colegio que venía de un lugar un
horno donde habían incinerado a personas
y él quedó como como así pero si eso
pasó fue en Alemania en en auschwitz en
el evento también participan víctimas
Allí está Fabián Becerra
Hoy es un día que no se olvidarán en el
inicio de lo que por años hemos venido
solicitando entre los asistentes
comunidad internacional pero también el
asesor de mancuso Juan Carlos villamizar
lo que hemos visto en Colombia
es que negar la posibilidad de los
responsables de reincorporarse a la
sociedad y de resarcir sus
acciones lo que produce es el rearme y
la continuación del conflicto armado
desde una cárcel de Estados Unidos El
antes temible mancuso Ahora pide perdón
se ofrece a ir a encontrar las víctimas
en fosas de Venezuela y solicita al
estado Que se cumpla el deseo de Fabián
recibe Por fin una respuesta del hombre
que tanto dolor le ha causado como se
dieron cuenta que con el terreno aquí va
a colaborar para hacer la plazoleta de
la paz la verdad la memoria la memoria y
que nunca más
el acto termina con el canciller Álvaro
Leiva plantando un árbol es el primer
paso para convertir Juan frío en un
lugar de recuerdo el auschwitz de
Colombia